[Music]
well
if your opponent or a friend playing
the classical london system regularly
then the following trap
i'm about to show you not only give you
a great victory
but even though let's say he doesn't
fall for the trap
you still obtain a very good position
after d4 my recommendation is you start
with
d6 and when the classical london system
players start with knight tower 3
we play this weight defense move
bishop to g4 so idea is very obvious
in some lines we will take that knight
and
give white a double pawn but
london player doesn't bother about all
this
they continue with their fixed layout
bishop to f4 and after our crafty move
knight to d7 if you check the database
there are roughly 2 000 games
continue with the usual move e3
well guess what white player
straight away fallen into our trappy
territory
and the trappy business start with this
remarkable move e5
okay black is attacking the bishop
so white has to take it and after d
captures e5
white bishop has a three location and
amongst them
two of them are outright bad
well first time when i played this
edition
one of my friend which has a strength of
2200
continued with bishop captures e5
and clearly thinks that i blunder upon
but the matter of fact is it is now
white
who is losing with knight captures e5
what his idea was that he wants to first
exchange the queen
and now take my piece as
that bishop is not pinning anything
but what has been missed out is this
very deadly checkmate
so that's the reason why bishop captures
e5
is right out of the equation
the second move bishop to g5 is equally
very wrong and i can see you know the
answer
instantly yep bishop captures f3
counter-attacking the white queen if
queen takes bishop
then we can take the dark square bishop
and black emerge
with a p serve and the same story goes
if white first take our queen and when
we take his queen
at the end of the scenario once again
black emerge with a whole piece
advantage
so to cut the long story short here
white has the only response
namely bishop to g3 and after this
no prize for guessing black's obvious
response
yup you got it e5
now if you opponent see this position
first time then he
likely to make this blunder namely h3
which in fact roughly 300 people
has fallen into the only way to avoid
this trap
is to play queen to d4 which we are
going to look
at the end first let's check out
what happens if bishop to h3
well the answer is very obvious you
continue your pin
with bishop to h5 and now
white will love to play g4 but he cannot
as
his bishop is blocking the file
okay the majority of the games continue
with queen to d5
attacking the bishop but after knight to
f6
defending as well as attacking the queen
queen captures b7 what else and now
you don't play e captures f3 which
majority of the games
continues instead of that i propose this
very strong move rook to b8
which in fact finishing the game just
within
few moves well obviously enough
queen can't take on c7 because of the
end of the transaction
queen takes bishop takes and the move
rook to c8
two of the white pieces are hanging so
that's not the idea
the big point is white wants to take on
a7
and when we take on f3
white will be delighted to see bishop
capture c7
where at least he get rook for two minor
pieces
right and yes indeed it's true
and when i first time see this venetian
i said wow
is it real because black can play a very
calm move here
queen to c8 allowing white to capture
over rook
but after that this deciding blow
queen captures c2
and no matter after this whatever white
plays
he is going to lose the game
obviously there are two threats number
one we have
bishop to b4 check and number two very
nasty one
f captures g2 and then queen to d1
a checkmate so white needs to parry both
of them
and accordingly knight to d2 is the only
move
but after our knight to e4 i think white
is
already busted his knight is hanging
the only good way to defend this knight
is to play queen to e5
which in fact doesn't solve the problem
as black has this tactical resource
knight captures d2 queen captures d2
and now the stunning blow f captures g2
and white can pack his bag and go home
well he has two options number one
if he takes our queen then after bishop
to b for check
sadly enough this queen has to go
back to d2 whereupon we take this queen
and create our queen with a huge
material advantage so that's
not a good option for white what happens
if he's simply here take the g2 pawn
well that's where the final piece of
puzzle comes
into the picture did you see a killer
blow here
you are a genius if you see bishop to b4
bam
so now by force we are winning the white
queen
as the queen cannot take this bishop
in the view of queen to e2
checkmate so this is one of the high
profile trap
in this line which you definitely want
to watch out
when you play this variation
now before we leave the last thing i
want to point out that
white can avoid this trap by playing
queen to d4
however i think after this black get
instant equalizer with the following
sequence
knight to f6 defending our bishop and
threatening
e captures f3 so white plays
knight to e5 counter attacking our
bishop
but what i like about this variation is
rapid quick
development of the black pieces so first
we play bishop to c5 attacking the queen
queen to a4 and now simply
dropping the bishop back to f5
black has a huge leading development and
as suggested by the engine the base
sequence
goes as follow knight captures d7
bishop captures d7 white plays queen to
b3
and here we have the last trick on the
table
starting with a5
okay white should play a4 and game will
remain balanced
but many of you will ask the simple
question
why not taking on b7 after all
this is what white was aiming for it
right
well simply he cannot touch this
poison pawn the answer is very obvious
you play bishop to b6
stopping all escape route for the white
queen
and one of the game from the database
finished very quickly
where white played this blunder move
knight to c3
which result in the loss of queen with
rook to a7 and the white sweetie
disappear from the ball
so that's it guys i hope with this mini
lecture
now you are confident enough to play
this line
against the classical london setup
player
and i wish you best of luck for playing
in your own games
thank you for watching this video feel
free to like subscribe and comment
and i will meet you in my next episode
very soon
bye and take care